his name again right Tanya can you
unmute yourself and say you know bring
up the issue that you oh hey yeah that
was actually me Tanya it was mostly an
answer to the comment that came up in
the Q&A before when was talking about
that was not me
this has been factored somebody wrote in
the chat I presume but I didn't see it
but Chhavi you read it out that d-wave
is factoring large numbers and so I
pasted that I linked the paper which is
showing that the d-wave approach can't
actually get big speed ups they try to
do something what's at solvers so
there's more announcer than a question I
can paste the chat the link here as well
so this something that you posted on the
chapter of the tadka somebody's very
wait what it says the chat now you know
what maybe somebody recorded hold on you
probably will get an email afterwards
with the chat log but I mean host anyway
now you got a pointer from Tonya on
Daniel chapter so here's the but I mean
that's specific to the debates thing and
I think it was a very small aside I mean
the nearly but you and I see motivating
the whole area by saying a factoring of
the drove in the future but not quite
yet and I don't think with that
statement so we are getting closer sure
but I don't think that the debate thing
is getting us anywhere closing it is not
it's nothing which gives you a
exponential speed-up
I mean sewing Shor's algorithm brings it
down to polynomial time and this one is
I mean such solving you know it's MP MP
complete so we don't expect that to be
polynomial time anybody can be a
concrete speed I mean you know even
getting a concrete speed-up over the
best classical algorithm is it's
non-trivial des so I think this is an
indication that
quantum computers me the threat of
quantum computing for factor in
basically photography is a real threat I
mean it's not an immediate danger but
it's a serious issue in the long run one
of the things that they were talking
about in chat which again I don't
remember who it was is the d-wave is
working currently about some approaches
to substitute Sun and I don't know what
versions of subsets on hopefully this
would be you know if you have methods to
use these dewayne machines for sat
solving the deaths yeah so the same yeah
it's not surprising that it the same it
could be used to speed up a subset Sam
and but then what you can achieve in the
end if you are targeting the NP hard
version of the problem of course is
necessarily limited I'm just wondering
if you can put up your slides with that
you rush through with the most kitchen
now yeah yeah I can do that I see I need
to move them a different window I think
you say sharing I know I know the
promise that you can only sure Santa is
showing on my screen if I have multiple
desktops and one of them is not sure win
then zone doesn't see it and I just
needed to move a few windows around now
assume disappeared okay let me
does anybody else have more questions as
it just between me and the nearly didn't
understand slides so I had a question
regarding so you explained four
different ways of multiplication oh so I
wanted to know if there if there is some
sort of inherent similarity between all
these four methods or these are ones
actually different from each other like
are they sort of semantically equivalent
in a mathematical sense or are they so -
well yes and no in the sense that
addition is addition so this is just 1
so the numbers are done in the same way
but the four methods as far as I can
tell they are using these additivity in
different ways there are different
methods to use the same additivity
property so it's not that so there are
different schemes in the end so that
you're performing the way you perform
operations on the cipher texts it's
somehow different and this also is
something you can see that the result is
different if you look at the security
assumptions which they produce and also
the level of efficiency they produce so
you can still think of them as different
variants of the same very high level
general idea overall it's used the
linearity property to do multiplication
but the linearity properties are used in
ways that I think have genuinely
different you can go back to the number
3 you can see this life now corrector
yes we can yeah so the previous method
in the second method you're saying that
you need super polynomial factors right
mm-hmm
where does that come in due to what is
it oh that's because so ii meant order
each time you do a multiplication day
noise is grow
win by a certain amount and before you
perform enough operations to implement
the bootstrapping the noise is grown by
a super polynomial amount and that does
not happen so that's it three method
three supports so in the second method
the noise growth is the symmetric so
given two cybertek with a certain amount
of noise you combine them together and
you have an amount of noise that if you
change the order of the to cybertechs
you still get the same so the and if you
look at the definition of the second
method it is the same tensor product of
two ciphertext so the operation itself
is symmetric so the third method is an
operation to combine it two schemes is a
matter it's not symmetric it doesn't if
you use it to implement arbitrary
circuits also in that case you can get
super polynomial growth but it happens
that you can implement you can give a
specialized implementation of the
bootstrap in that when implemented using
the third method only require polynomial
noise noise growth and that's from the
GSW yes it is the GSW I mean what I
described is a different perspective is
a different way to build the GSW in a
sense you can think of it as so this is
a multiplication by hoe morphic
decryption so the way I like to present
it is that you are decrypting and so
your your decrypt in a cipher x1 under a
and to multiple of the secret key and
that gives an encryption of m1 m2 but
they are used in a very asymmetric way
to ciphertext 1 is used as a decryption
key and the other one is used as a
actual ciphertext being decrypted I'm
not sure which light is best
- hey so I don't know anybody has
questions about an altercation 3 because
he went really quickly so maybe with any
money because then I would move on to
for any questions and a request to see
it in more detail here's a question
and then my question was do you have a
recommendation for a resource to know
why lattices are resistant to quantum
computing no I think that's so that's a
recurring question and people ask how do
I know that people are even trying not
to do it and as far as I can tell
people are trying but unsuccessfully and
there's a problem that if you try to
break them using quantum computer
quantum algorithms and you fail it's
hard to publish a paper on that so so
there's a sample bias so you only gets
to see attacks when they work and this
until I suggested sometime in the past
we should find a way to document also at
times by you know knowledgeable people
people that we know are expert in the
area so if we should find a way so that
even those and it's something you can
read about now so there is there are a
few papers out there that somehow use
the quantum watch if santen thing in the
lattice setting by it's very very
limited right now and there is very
little to to read more it most
importantly you were asking what should
I read to now that it doesn't work and
it didn't get written so whatever I
didn't try this and one of the things
that I've been working on personally but
I know people that tried to do it in
some cases they even came up with a
candidate solutions and algorithms which
in at a closer look turned out to be
wrong incorrect and I mean I don't think
there is anything to be ashamed about
you try to do something and it doesn't
work even the inside that you get from
doing that that would be interesting for
many people to read by it's just very
hard for this type of
so this type of work to get documented
so I don't know if anybody else in the
audience's already Simon's Institute has
other reservations about how we could
address cities them looks like no it
does yeah well okay actually our first
response to that to the original
question which is just like what would
be more surprising is a quantum attack
that's not a classical attack right like
there aren't that many examples of
things that quantum computers give
exponential speed ups for so like in
some sense we're kind of biased because
it happens to be the case that factoring
in discrete log or some of those few
examples but in general like we
shouldn't expect that and also just
another example of a failed algorithm
quantum algorithm or latus problems is
Oh des lwe reduction rate I mean that
was the original purpose was to find a
fishing in an efficient quantum
algorithm so like people have been
thinking about it since at least you
know whenever Ted was working on that
and so there's another question here in
the chat could we hope for a truly
practical scheme by finding the right
algebraic lattice right in quotes or
have we exhausted our search on space to
define lattices eg torus actually tried
to do that could even ask for the right
algebraic lattices for specific
applications such as running statistics
on data interesting so yeah it depends
what you mean by truly practical in some
sense we already have three practical
schemes for some definition of truly
practical something that you can run yes
there are schemes that you can run and
as you mentioned that there are also
there are libraries implement in these
schemes
now TFA 3 is using encryption that the
torus I I don't think that using the
torso makes any difference whatever is
achieved by that scheme can also be
achieved without using the tall route so
so sometime just looking at things in
terms of efficiency does and necessarily
provides the best understanding but
there are there are certainly reasonable
candidates that are being considered use
on the application side I'm not an
expert when it comes to applications I
think
be extending that question my question
is can you in some sense almost have a
compiled compiler that would say that
for a particular application one kind of
multiplication say they're talking about
one kinds of a cryptosystem or lattice
but what can even ask that about
specific application methods can you
sort of semi automatically decide which
is the right multiplication to use for
an application
in principle yes is an in fact there are
even some projects trying to attempt to
do that
the me right now even in providing a
good you know description taxonomy of
the various techniques in a modular way
so that you can more easily mix and
match different schemes is something
that is not that easy to extract from
the published published literature so it
sure it can be done but but but there is
work to be done to get to get there okay
any more questions
otherwise I'd love it if you moved on to
that modification before and we won't
keep you past 4:30 any more questions
okay so when you when you propose this
one of my question was you always you
were suggesting in the context of
bootstrapping so the idea of this method
for which I was proposing the fuel
scheme is that in Sam bootstrapping
procedures specifically in the
bootstrapping procedures based on GSW
so this starting from the work of week
and maybe not theis itcs 2014 that was
the first scheme it achieved the
bootstrapping with polynomial with
polynomial approximation factor
now those bootstrapping procedures also
allow the computation of pretty much
arbitrary functions on the ciphertext
that is being most rapid now you why it
is not as when I say arbitrary functions
you have to keep in mind that your
bootstrap in a single ciphertext so it's
not that doesn't give us a chi the fact
that you can compute arbitrary functions
for free so about what you can do is to
use addition to combine ciphertext one
in ciphertext to into a single one and
then during bootstrapping you can apply
an arbitrary function on C and there is
this combination of binary addition and
computation of arbitrary union unary
functions that when put together allowed
to perform arbitrary computations for
example addition modulo four and
division by two with rounding so that's
enough to implement all binary guides so
that's the yeah so is basically the idea
of pushing some of the computation
inside the bootstrap in the procedure is
one of the key elements and that's what
I call gate gate bootstrapping it is
something that now is being used also in
that there are a few other remote recent
papers using this idea of pushing
computation in the gate for example the
tfhe scheme is using the same type of
multiplication multiplication by
addition and then doing division by two
during bootstrapping the difference is
that in TFA tree well on one hand they
are using real arithmetic instead of
modulo Q which I don't think has any
impact on the you just get the same
results I don't think it makes any
difference they are using a different
bootstrapping bootstrapping procedure
than the one that was used in my paper
so you can think of that as an
alternative method so you could use the
same method also to bootstrap a few
cipher texts in very recent paper on e
print with yuri [ __ ] of where we
compare the two bootstrapping procedures
in the context of few and this idea of
pushing some of the computation inside
the bootstrapping
also appears has been used in the
chimera paper which some of the authors
with a tree where they describe a method
to convert between different fhe schemes
and so that's pretty standard that you
can use bootstrap in to go from one
scheme to the other but then they
combine it with the idea is that as you
convert and one scheme into the other
using bootstrapping you can also draw
some computation inside the
bootstrapping procedure to get a
conversion which is also achieving
something useful at the same time so it
improves performance you can optimize
the whole computation by pushing some of
the computation inside the bootstrap
instead excellent thank you any other
questions
anybody
so I think that when we crawl on mute
and clap for you thank you my talk and
see you soon guys
is there a lapis seminar tomorrow
excuse the in Thursday yes there will be
I'm sending the email right now but
there will be one okay so I guess I'll
see you then I had a request oh yeah
would it be possible to make lights are
always I think they're always posted at
some point by sign I will send them
right away to Simon and to dress and I
think they get posted on the website
together with the talk so they are
easily they will be a recording of the
talk and the slides available there on
the page make you section also what
section and the current FAQ section the
questions and answers they D be oh yeah
yeah yeah so this was I didn't record it
by eye so I so it was being recorded
this so I think that there and that
that's why they recorded it so that they
can mean to require some stitch in
putting the two videos together biting
that's the plan man okay okay okay